vor drei monaten ist das passiert auf
jeden fall werde ich in dieser woche
erstmal basics der musikproduktion
lernen und meinen eigenen song
produzieren und anschließend versuchen
ihnen auf spotify aufzuladen und da ich
keinen plan von musik habe ich mir mache
es an getränken geschnappt was willst du
machen so tour-sieg richtung wesel david
guetta jetzt jetzt könnte so eine
richtig elektronisch für mich als ich
das schon mit fertigen song mach jetzt
mal die melodie kommt
aber es ist echt schwer sich eine
melodie einfallen zu lassen
die schwierigste entscheidung war wohl
der name und ich entscheide mich für
diplom jetzt heißt es daumen drücken
dass der song angenommen und von spotify
akzeptiert wird es ist ein brauch
spotify worte fahrgästen strangers
gefühlt auf jeden fall jetzt eine krasse
woche ich hatte ja für den song nur drei
tage zeit das mein song wie findest du
den geil
das ist absolut stock wurden heute drei
monate und 370.000 streams später hatte
ich von spotify mein gehalt bekommen
also natürlich nicht buchstäblich dass
das ist wahrscheinlich mahnung vom
finanzamt den betrag habe ich natürlich
digital bekommen was für mich nur ein
glückliches kleines experiment war ist
für viele der große traum mit musik geld
verdienen durch das internet sollte das
ja eigentlich leichter sein denn je aber
wie viel verdient man wirklich mit
spotify itunes oder apple music und wie
verändern die streaming-dienste die art
und weise wie du und ich musik hören
könnte ich den song den ich ohne
erfahrung erstellt haben mit
datenanalysen und algorithmus
auswertungen der musikindustrie so
optimieren dass es garantiert ein hit
wird dieses video wird unterstützt von
wimmelt manie um zu verstehen wie man
heutzutage merken sie sich geld
verdienen sollten uns da erst ansehen
wie sich die musikindustrie und die art
wie und wo wir musik machen verändert
hat natürlich ist es immer noch möglich
über konzerte den verkauften cds oder
das singen auf einer hochzeit geld zu
verdienen ganz modernen sind dann
natürlich musik streaming anbieter wie
zum beispiel spotify apple music oder
dieser wo man früher geld für eine cd
ausgegeben und diese rauf und runter
gehört hat bekommt man heute die option
ein einzelnes abonnement abzuschließen
und erhält dafür mehr musik als man im
leben jemals hören könnte ja wirklich
würde man ab sofort versuchen alle 50
millionen titel auf spotify am stück zu
hören wäre man nach 273 jahren erst
fertig und das nur wenn keine neuen
dazukommen würden jederzeit können wir
einen neuen song entdecken egal wo wir
uns gerade befinden
teilweise weiß man gar nicht wer das
kunstwerk geschaffen hat von dem man
sich gerade emotional auf rutschen lässt
weil man einfach im hintergrund eine
playlist hört diese veränderungen wirkte
sich natürlich auch auf die
musikindustrie aus der wir jetzt einfach
mal frech das motiv unterstellen
maximale gewinne erzielen zu wollen muss
sind er zum beispiel dass songs immer
kürzer werden die durchschnittsdauer
eines
der sank von 2013 mit drei minuten und
50 sekunden auf 3 minuten und 30
sekunden in 2018 und spotify wird dazu
wohl maßgeblich beigetragen haben man
wird dort nämlich immer dann bezahlt
wenn sich jemand 30 sekunden des eigenen
jedes anhört unabhängig von der
gesamtlänge auf der halbstündigen
bahnfahrt zur arbeit hört der hörer also
mittlerweile 8,57 songs aus dem album
seines lieblings musikers und nicht nur
7,8 3 klingt nicht nach einem großen
unterschied sind aber 9,5 prozent mehr
streams und dadurch auch fast zehn
prozent mehr geld in der gleichen zeit
mainzer fans übrigens nur zwei minuten
und 46 sekunden
heißt das jetzt dass ich mit den 370.000
streams mega viel verdient hat wie viel
das genau war jeweils von spotify itunes
und apple music und ja das sind zwei
verschiedene dinge
kehren wir später bevor man auch nur ein
cent musik verdienen klein braucht
natürlich erstmal ein konto auf dass die
einkünfte ausgezahlt werden können ich
habe mir vor kurzem ein konto bei wird
eröffnet wer wird unser heutiger sponsor
bietet modernes mobile banking die mir
alles unkompliziert per app auf eurem
smartphone oder liegen können nach der
kontoeröffnung für die er nicht mehr
euer haus verlassen müsst erhaltet ihr
zusätzlich diese kohle metall karte mit
der überall ohne gebühren zahlen können
bei jedem einsatz der karte alte tier
von village zehn prozent cashback
wodurch euch jeden monat bis zu 20 euro
dazu verdienen kann und das funktioniert
nicht nur in deutschland sondern überall
auf der welt aber meiner meinung nach
das beste feature ist die pocket
funktion mit der er ganz easy
verschiedene unter konten einrichten und
eure geldeingänge hin und her buchen
können das war einfach die organisation
von finanzen komplett vor allem für
selbständige wie mich zum beispiel
blickt gerne auf den link in der video
beschreibung eröffnet ein kostenloses
konto bei wittmann ii und erhaltet jeden
monat bis zu 20 euro cashback nicht nur
die song länge hat sich verändert und
damit die zuhörer am ball bleiben
verschieben extrem viele jazzmusiker den
saftigen teil eines videos also den
refrain oder druck direkt an den anfang
wenn man davon erfolgreich attached
wurde watermann danach natürlich als
hörer bis der partie erneut einsetzt was
so eine prozentual längere dauer führt
und das führt wiederum dazu dass spotify
den song häufiger vorschlägt auch hier
konnte man sich vor dem musik streaming
einfach viel mehr zeit lassen was zb
durch einen dramatischen spannungsaufbau
für ein besseres insgesamt das
hörerlebnis gesorgt hatte vergleichbar
ist es ungefähr damals dass ich auch in
meinen videos am anfang schon im
ankünder worum es geht und was der
zuschauer zu erwarten hat um den
spannungsbogen zu bauen im vergleich
dazu mit sich bei einem
kein medium dem film viel viel mehr zeit
genommen
der zuschauer hat er in der regel schon
gezahlt oder mal zumindest in sich sehr
viel zeit eingeplant und das ganze ding
zu gucken und wird nicht nach drei
minuten abschalten wenn doch nichts mehr
spannendes passiert ist genau so konnten
sich natürlich schallplatten oder cds
viel längere intros leisten weil man
viel mehr darin investiert war und
einfach nicht tausende davon zuhause
rumliegen hatte der hörer hat in der
regel ja schon geld ausgegeben und jetzt
deswegen ja trotzdem anhören und durch
die längere potenziellen vielen zu sehen
wir das erlebnis haben gibt es
eigentlich besondere instrumente oder
ein ganzes genre das für den algorithmus
am besten geeignet ist spotify
analysiert tatsächlich jedes lied nach
tempo instrumenten dauer höhen und
tiefen klang farbe usw aber auch nach
emotionen wie fröhlich traurig oder
melancholisch mittlerweile unterteilt
die platform leader doch tatsächlich in
über 1.500 jahres mit datensätzen wie
diesen kann dann genau analysiert werden
welche song länge stimmung oder welche
rhythmen am meisten geschrieben werden
und bei welcher stelle im sommer
abgeschaltet wird oder zu welcher stelle
die zuhörer sogar vorspulen schon längst
strukturieren große musiklabels nach
diesem wissen ihre songs moment mal kann
ich dieses wissen auch dazu nutzen um
einen eigenen song mainstream tauglicher
und damit erfolgreicher zu machen ich
kann es zumindest mal versuchen laut
analysen der chart songs der letzten
jahre kommt der refrain also der
höhepunkt bei erfolgreichen songs
innerhalb der ersten 50 sekunden wie
sieht das dann zum beispiel beim einem
song aus ich habe schon komplett
vergessen wie das funktioniert
in meinem fall kommt der erste höhepunkt
bei 25 sekunden deswegen damit den punkt
schon abgehakt und der nächste punkt ist
das tempo des songs das hier in beats
per minute gemessen wird welches bei
chartsongs im durchschnitt bei 114 beats
per minute liegt das muss jetzt nicht
heißen dass ich genau diese zahl für
meinen song besser anhört aber wir
können ja mal probieren aktuell bei 146
also deutlich schneller schrauben wir
das mal runter all the way auf 114 1
ja also es hat definitiv auch etwas
klingt ja ganz interessant da will ich
glaube nicht dass es das ist was meinem
song fehlt
als nächsten punkt hat sich ergeben dass
songs mit vertrauten instrumenten und
klängen erfolgreicher sind als welcher
mit experimenteller den klängen und
darfeld unser song mit diesen spacey
klängen definitiv durchs raster deswegen
probleme mit den gleichen song mal aus
mit verschiedenen instrumenten die man
besser kennt so hört sich die man nur
die aktuell an
[Musik]
ok wenn ihr einmal das klavier dafür
sie haben als ein normales klavier und
gitarre
[Musik]
diesen pass könnte man auch so eine
normale basket ersetzen
komplette rohentwurf nur nicht mit
diesen spacey instrumenten die ich
genommen habe sondern mit klassischen
instrumenten klavier bass und gitarre
hört sich dann so an
[Musik]
auch echt interessant dass man in dieser
version zu hören aber ich denke nicht
dass ich dieses wissen aus der analyse
von hunderten chart-hits eins zu eins
auf meinen song anwenden lässt
ich glaube dass der song zumindest von
der richtung her in die er geht gut so
ist wie er ist und ganz gut die sims
wave schiene bedient hat und natürlich
fallen dank meiner reichweite
erfolgreich genug war
aber wie erfolgreich genau wir kommen zu
den einnahmen
im juni waren es von spotify 615 dollar
über apple music knapp 51 dollar und
über itunes zwar eur 27 das verrückt
also ich hätte gar nicht damit gerechnet
dass noch irgendwo außerhalb von spotify
leuten das überhaupt ansehen zugriffs
quellen hauptsächlich in deutschland
aber auch echt viele mit platz vier in
den jetzt denn jetzt haben sich im
letzten monat fast 500 leute den sondern
gehört im juni wurde er sorgen also fast
250.000 mal angehört wurde sind es also
zwei euro 46 pro stream was tatsächlich
so ziemlich die selbe cpm ist wie bei
meinem youtube kanal
wenn ich schon wissen wollte welche
experimente ich als nächstes machen und
auch schon ausschnitte davon sehen
möchtet folgt wir gerne auf instagram da
sage ich euch nämlich schon vorab coole
sachen und andere ausschnitt aus dem
leben und wenn er mich auf dieser reise
begleiten möchte dann folgt mir wir
immer auf diesen kanal und dann sehen
wir uns beim nächsten mal wieder was gut
[Musik]